hey Kiki Kiki Palmer brings her fashion
a game to the 2023 Met Gala come on
let's talk about it
the actress stuns in a Sergio Hudson
custom gown the materials made with a
multi-color pastel Tweed the dress
topped with a silk taffeta Opera coat
the Swarovski Crystal and pearl count
over 12
000. it's true is true so how did Kiki's
outfit come to life check out this video
of Sergio drawing the design
[Music]
thank you
this isn't the first time the singer
teamed up with Sergio for her Met Gala
look she rocked this stunner attending
her very first one in 2021
my luck was the finale look for Sergio
Hudson's most recent collection so it is
the bang bang boom pop okay
um you know and we got a little back out
moment
very much Diana inspired I'm sure you
could tell by the hair and the eye and
the glamor all of the things yes yes and
it's no surprise Kiki and Sergio keep
bringing the Glam On Fashion's biggest
night
[Music]
foreign